tout a commencé quand la gendarmerie
royale du canada est venue arrêter des
manifestants
la grc n'a aucune juridiction sur nous
le chef héréditaire
nous n'avons jamais cédé notre terre
contrairement à ce qui s'est passé dans
la majeure partie du canada à partir du
19ème siècle jusqu'au début du xxème
tout territoire à peu près du sang tout
prêt du milieu du canada est couvert par
des traités par lesquels les
britanniques et le gouvernement canadien
tenu la session officielle des terres
des autochtones
sur cette carte on voit les traités
signés par les premières nations
rien ou presque en colombie britannique
au québec et dans les maritimes
une formule que l'on entend de plus en
plus nous le rappelle nous remercions la
nation cas niang herrada de son
hospitalité en territoire d'en céder
l'avantagé effectivement je pense des
communautés c'est que finalement ils ont
conservé leurs droits ancestraux
donc on l'a vu la possibilité pour eux
de négocier des traités ce qu'on appelle
lé traité moderne comme la convention de
la baie james avec les cris et les
inuits dans le nord du québec en
colombie-britannique
les communautés se servent de leur
statut pour mieux négocier ou s'opposer
ceux qui ont été négligés au 18ème 19ème
sexe sont aujourd'hui ceux qui peuvent
revendiquer avec le plus de force devant
les tribunaux mais deux formes de
pouvoir s'opposent d'un côté les
conseils de bande qui gère les réserves
ils ont dit oui majoritairement aux
projets de gazoducs de l'autre les chef
héréditaire qui gère le territoire
ancestral et qui ne veulent pas que le
projet se construit sur leurs terres et
cette ferme opposition
on pourrait la retrouver ici au québec
dans le cas par exemple du pipeline
génome québec qui traverse à ses proches
en fait de plusieurs premières nations
qui auront certainement la rouatière par
rapport à s'ils souhaitent ou non que le
pipeline passe près de chez eux et
puisse avoir des impacts sur leur sur
leurs droits ancestraux des chefs des
premières nations rencontreront françois
legault au printemps pour parler de
leurs relations politiques
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal